bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro d'
enquête de région c'est une rubrique
souvent méprisé est pourtant
omniprésente sur nos écrans comme dans
les journaux les faits divers font
s'entremêler des thèmes qui ne nous
laisse pas indifférents comme la vie la
mort l'amour la haine et dans une région
qui a connu beaucoup d'affaires
judiciaires nous nous intéressons
aujourd'hui à ces crimes et nous nous
demandons pourquoi il nous fascine tant
nous évoquerons d'ailleurs certaines
affaires
dans cette émission notre intérêt pour
les faits divers pour leurs détails et
l'heure rebondissement est il de la
curiosité malsaine ou répond-t-il un
besoin réel d'informations pour coller
joie dans le fait divers
parce que c'est une histoire sciences à
suspense de trois quarts du temps et les
gens adorent les histoires certaines
affaires de disparition restent dans
l'impasse malgré les efforts et les
moyens déployés le risque de l'oubli
alourdi alors l'angoissante incertitudes
des proches quelquefois je me dis on me
dira elle est décédée
c'est terrible à dire je le dirai enfin
voilà vous savez ya des personnes qui
veulent savoir comment ça s'est passé
c'est pas ça qui nous intéresse de
savoir ce qu'elle a envie pas
dans la sphère des disparues de l'yonne
la défaillance de l'action judiciaire a
longtemps permis à emile louis
d'échapper au jugement
lorsqu'on démarre une affaire concerne
lorsqu'on tire des 1re ficelle
franchement on se rend pas compte parce
qu'on pense que les toutes les
institutions sont sont dirigés par des
gens normaux qui vont réagir à des viols
dans les institutions à ce terrain et
et on pense que tout va fonctionner que
la justice fonctionne que l'état
fonctionne or ça n'a pas été le cas
crime en bourgogne franche comté s'est
tout de suite dans 4 de région
[Musique]
le
parmi les affaires récentes que notre
région a connu il yal'affaire narumi du
nom de cette jeune étudiante japonaise
disparu sur le campus de besançon et
dont le corps reste introuvable et puis
il ya la faire alexia d'aval cette jeune
femme partie faire un jogging est
retrouvée morte près de gray en
haute-saône s'est fait divers alimentent
nos conversations il nous choque il nous
révoltent parfois mais ce qui est sûr
c'est qu'on en parle plus souvent qu'on
ne le croit
qui n'a pas été séduit un jour par cette
petite musique qui vous plante dans le
coeur des mots horribles des mots de
crimes de vengeance d'assassinât des
mots si noir qu'il tâche les doigts et
vous font les mains sales bien sûr on
peine à comprendre ses sentiments
brouillon qui nous envahissent à la
lecture des faits divers naïvement nous
avons cru trouver une réponse dans la
rue hors la rue et pudique elle n'aime
pas parler de ces choses là je crois
qu'il ya des choses plus important que
les faits divers les faits divers ça
parce que sannois la vraie information
c'est pas le genre de chose que je
regarde ça me fait un peu le couteau
dans la plaie avec un accident qu'est-ce
qui se passe les gens qui ont l'air yard
on est tous pareils assez humain les
crimes
va parce que j'ai commis moi même ça
n'intéresse pas spécialement à ceux des
autres
des fois je suis un peu jaloux mais non
c'est non rien de spécial elle a
travaillé pendant 30 ans pour un grand
quotidien de l'est de la france
le sens le sexe le drame les bas
morceaux de l'information elle connaît
et elle n'est pas vraiment étonné par ce
déni autour du fait divers
[Musique]
ceux qui disent ça sont ceux qui le
lendemain se précipitent dans les
caisses que pour acheter les journaux ou
quoi en fait on a besoin d'informations
quand on apprend un fait divers un
enfant qui a disparu des choses comme ça
on veut savoir
on veut savoir si on la retrouve et on
veut savoir qui l'a pris c'est normal
que l'on réponde à une certaine
curiosité qui n'est pas malsaine qui est
normal pourquoi les gens adorent le fait
divers
parce que c'est une histoire assume ce à
suspense des trois quarts du temps et
les gens adorent les histoires
qu'est ce que vous a appris le fait
divers au long de votre carrière
l'humain l'humain ce important un
véritable massacre perpétré par cet
homme christian dornier jeune
journaliste
annette vial a dû se rendre à lux yole
la tuerie de luxe yole le coup de folie
d'un jeune agriculteur c'était en 1989 à
35 km de besançon
autant de cibles visées à bout portant
presque méthodiquement 14 morts
trois enfants
on est d'arriver les gens étaient encore
couchés par terre c'était c'était c'est
épouvantable quoi mais les gens qui
étaient directement touché c'est ce qui
nous parlait c'est ce qui nous racontait
qui nous disait mon père il était à tel
endroit qui nous aimons gamma et l'état
tel endroit et c'est parce qu'ils
avaient besoin de s'exprimer on a besoin
ce moment là et puis d'un seul coup sont
arrivés les gens des villages en voisin
et à ce moment là on ne sait gens-là
nous ont agressés en nous disant qu'on
était des voyeurs etc
c'est une partie de la vie qu'il faut
qu'il faut révéler qu'il faut expliquer
pourquoi il a fait ça dans quelles
circonstances comment etc
l'émission faites entrer l'accusé s'est
fait une spécialité des grandes affaires
judiciaires autopsié le crime l'expliqué
la doyenne des émissions de faits divers
a traité près de 240 cas 240 numéro une
véritable bibliothèque sanglante qui
dure depuis 18 ans brigitte muller quand
les gendarmes sont arrivés chez elle
elle baignait dans une mare de sang
elle était couchée devant le train
électrique de ses enfants le visage
emporté par un coup de feu chaque
histoire demande six mois de travail
faites entrer l'accusé ne traite que des
affaires résolues jugé classe et une
règle pour ne pas gêner le travail de la
justice pour la rédactrice en chef du
magazine
le fait divers permet d'observer la
société de biais c'est pas le caractère
sordide des faits qui nous déterminent
c'est ce qu'ils disent de la société
c'est ce qu'ils disent du fonctionnement
de la justice de la police du
fonctionnement d'une communauté d'une
profession d'un milieu d'une région
c'est ce que la ferdi de l'âme humaine
un tueur à la hache au royaume de
l'automobile montbéliard sochaux belfort
le pays du joug
l'homme a sévi quatre fois pendant le
crâne de s'éviter comme d'autres coupes
du c'est le monstre c'est toujours
l'autre c'est toujours celui qui a tué
quand on s'intéresse à la vie judiciaire
on s'aperçoit que la frontière elle est
très très très très fines qu'on peut
basculer très vite et clôt monstre vient
n'a pas il ya que des hommes qui font
des actes monstrueux le fait divers
rapportés dans les médias aurait donc
une vertu pédagogique peut être même
civique
reste alors cette énigme comment
expliquer l'adhésion en masse du public
autour d'un crime en novembre 2010 est à
gray en haute-saône
une marche blanche rassembler près de
5000 personnes la sphère alexia cette
joggeuse découverte assassinée dans un
bois a marqué les esprits
pour cet universitaire spécialiste en
criminologie rien d'étonnant nous autres
humains avons besoin de compatir ça crée
du lien le fait de discuter dans une
affaire s'offenser devant l'abject d'un
crime mais à plusieurs
voilà ce qui s'est passé c'est terrible
tout s'accorde sur le terrifiant d'une
affaire certes salle les mais du coup il
ya un partage une communion quelque part
dans le ressenti dans le tragique du
drame qui va raffermir les liens sociaux
le partage la communion autour d'alexia
ont bien eu lieu dans plusieurs villes
de france
mais les médias en surexposant ce crime
note il pas agit comme un miroir
déformant on a tous des angoisses des
peurs et ses phénomènes criminels vont
venir cristallisées ces angoisses c'est
vrai que cette affaire est tragique mais
dans ces dix dernières années le
le nombre de joggeuses morte c'est de
l'ordre de 8 donc un peu moins d'une par
an c'est très peu au regard de la
réalité des affaires criminelles et on a
plus de chances de se tuer en voiture ou
mais c'est au niveau du spectacle
beaucoup plus impressionnant ça va venir
davantage marqué les esprits et donc
entretenir un certain mythe qui est
déformé par rapport à la réalité
criminelle n'a jamais été aussi dans
l'histoire de france en sécurité tout
cas les crimes de sang ont
proportionnellement à la population
baisser les statistiques sont sans appel
on tue deux fois moins en france qu'il y
a quinze ans selon l'observatoire
national de la délinquance ond compte un
peu plus de 6 100 homicides y chaque
année soit moins de 2 par jour
dans trois quarts des cas l'assassin est
un proche de la victime
mais quels que soient ces chiffres avec
nous et malgré nous le crime reste
toujours une catégorie majeure du débat
social
[Musique]
eric mathais vous êtes procureur de la
république ici à dijon on vient de
s'intéresser à cette fascination pour
les crimes et les faits divers en
général est ce que c'est quelque chose
que vous vous constatez aussi dans votre
métier
bien sûr ça fascine les gens parce que
on se dit que ça peut arriver à tout le
monde mais c'est aussi souvent des gens
dont on se dit mais qui sont ils sont
ils des monstres pour avoir commis des
faits de cette nature
qu'est ce qui les a amenés qu'est ce qui
les a amenés là donc il ya à la fois un
sentiment de sa peut nous arriver on
peut être victime de main et puis d'un
autre côté voilà pourquoi cette personne
là et avec cette idée que c est ce que
ce sont des monstres ou non et en même
temps c'est le questionnement même de la
justice a de savoir qu'est ce qui les a
amenés là pourquoi ils ont fait ça
d'essayer de comprendre la personnalité
du prévenu
bien sûr on s'intéresse toujours à
essayer de comprendre parce qu'on juge
les faits bien entendu mais on juge
aussi un homme avec son passé des choses
qui aggravent des choses qui atténue sa
responsable peut y avoir des
circonstances intervient sur et je suis
j'ai souvent discuté avec des jurés qui
qui ont été juré ils disent que il
pensait pas que c'était aussi compliqué
de juger une personne parce que à part
tellement home on sait que tel criminel
ou telle personne qui a fait des faits
très graves
lui-même dans son passé a été victime 2
on comprend d'abord un peu mieux le
procès qu'est-ce qui a pu l'amener là et
puis c'est plus difficile d'avoir un
jugement très péremptoire sur la
personne
erick mathé vous par exemple vous êtes
procuré la république aujourd'hui vous
avez aussi été passionné par ses crimes
par ces faits divers c'est ça qui fait
une vocation de magistrats alors en fait
moi personnellement c'était plutôt les
études de droit un peu classique et
pendant mes études de droit je me suis
intéressé à la justice j'ai ensuite
passé concours de la magistrature et
pendant mon stage en faire un grand
stade juridictionnelle j'ai été fasciné
par la façon dont le parquet fonctionner
parce que c'est un travail en équipe
le procureur sait que ses collaborateurs
et puis les relations avec les services
de police et de gendarmerie et bien sûr
rechercher des énigmes et lui essayait
de
de trouver les preuves et puis d'avoir
une bonne décision ensuite il ya deux
facettes du procureur il ya l'enquète et
puis il ya aussi le ministère public
celui qui accuse qu'on appelle
l'accusation d'ailleurs lorsque les
policiers les gendarmes font des
enquêtes sur des affaires des délits ou
des crimes et lorsqu'ils ont arrêté une
personne en garde à vue ils le font sous
la direction du procureur d'un comique
qui s'assure que l'enquêté régulière que
ont en effet toutes les recherches
nécessaires pour arriver à la
manifestation de la vérité mais il ya
une deuxième phase est qui est plus
connu c'est effectivement à l'audience
correctionnelle c'est lui qui représente
l'intérêt général et qui demande une
peine au tribunal en fonction de sa
conviction
[Musique]
chaque matin à la faveur des grandes
affaires criminelles et puis
malheureusement des attentats que la
france a connu on connaît un peu mieux
aujourd'hui le fonctionnement de la
justice
ce que vous pensez que ça a changé le
regard de nos citoyens sur le monde
judiciaire
je pense que par rapport au début de ma
carrière il est procuré les particuliers
communiquent beaucoup plus donc on un
peu vulgariser la fonction de procureur
et puis le fonctionnement de la justice
on le voit d'ailleurs aux audiences il
ya quelques années les gens disaient
très souvent votre honneur parce que là
l'image principale qu'on avait comme les
états unis c'était la procédure
américaine
la procédure française est très
particulière et donc on voit que
maintenant les gens se trompent - parce
qu'ils sont plus habitués alors c'est
aussi parce qu'il ya plus je pense de
fiction qui sont qui présente le
fonctionnement de la justice ou de la
police et de la justice
la gendarmerie française mais c'est
aussi parce que les gens je pense le
connaissent me disais à la faveur des
grandes affaires criminelles est ce que
il y en a plus ou est ce que finalement
elles sont tout simplement plus
médiatisés on parlait il ya un instant
de la faire alexia laval où la sphère
narumi du côté de la franche comté on
pourrait parler des grandes affaires
aussi côté bourgogne comme les disparues
de l'yonne où les disparus de la cie
c'est ce que s quitte parce qu'on en
parle plus nous les médias qu'on
al'impression presque qu'il y en a plus
très clairement oui
les statistiques sur une longue durée
montre que les affaires les plus graves
les crimes et en particulier les crimes
de sang les assassinats les enlèvements
les meurtres sont en diminution
constante depuis des années et des
années et il y a donc de moins en moins
et on voit bien dans les rôles d'assises
les affaires qui passe aux assises il ya
de plus en plus d'affaires de sexe de
moins en moins d'affaires de sont donc
vraiment la société est une société
globalement est une société française
est une société moins dangereuse
maintenant en termes de crimes qu il y a
quelques années et pourtant c'est pas du
tout l'impression qu'ils aient donné
c'est aussi parce que je pense ce que
vous disiez les affaires sont beaucoup
plus médiatisée maintenant on en parle
beaucoup plus qu'il y a un certain
nombre d'années c'est un bien pour aussi
qu'on en parle plus parce qu'on voit
dans le cadre des disparitions
inquiétantes dont on va parler dans
quelques instants que c'est important de
médiatiser ce type de disparition par
exemple ça peut aider le travail de la
justice bien sûr du reste le ministère
la justice il ya quelques années a mis
au point un système d' alerte enlèvement
et qui pour l'instant a été déclenchée a
à peu près une vingtaine de fois je
crois et à chaque fois qui a permis de
retrouver l'enfant parce que il y à une
médiatisation très importante on se rend
bien compte que le fait d'en parler
c'est utile en termes d' enquête et puis
je crois aussi que c'est utile en termes
de prévention
on sait bien qu'il ya des situations où
ça peut être dangereux de se promener
seul dans un endroit particulièrement on
est pas de ses procureurs qui disent
attention la médiatisation ça peut aussi
un pirate et l' enquête
rendent difficile cette enquête on pense
évidemment parce qu'elle est elle est
traitée à dijon à la sphère très
médiatique de la disparition et la mort
du petit grégory
on sait qu'au début les médias c'était
certes dans les années 80 les temps ont
changé mais on joue un rôle trouble par
moment dans cette enquête
il ya toujours un risque que la
médiatisation se transforme en une
violation du secret de l'enquêté et
notre responsabilité ici même si
maintenant on communique plus et on
s'est mieux aussi informer le public et
c'est normal c'est aussi pour éviter ça
c'est aussi pour être certain que home
essaye de bien faire là là des
partitions entre l'information du public
et puis les nécessités de l'enquêté et
quand même notre responsabilité numéro
un c'est bien arriver à faire en sorte
que l' enquête aboutisse et donc quand
je j'ai une affaire qui défraye la
chronique je le dis toujours aux
journalistes je vous donnerai des
informations que je peux vous donner
mais mon souci numéro un ça reste quand
même d'arriver à rechercher la vérité et
trouver la vérité judiciaire dans un
dossier et donc il faut qu'on soit
attentif parce que les dérives qui
existaient il ya quelques années sont
toujours susceptibles d'exister
maintenant eric mathais on parle
beaucoup de la justice on la connaît
mieux sans doute
et pourtant on la critique aussi souvent
on le voit régulièrement mais on peut
penser à la faveur du malaise chez les
policiers ou des surveillants de prison
plus récemment encore est-ce que vous
avez l'impression que la justice
aujourd'hui travaillent bien et qu'elle
a les moyens de faire son travail
alors les moyens pas tout à fait c'est
clair par exemple les
il ya des études au niveau du conseil de
l'europe donc des 47 pays de l'europe
qui démontre que par exemple il y a deux
fois moins de juges pour 100000
habitants deux fois moins de greffiers
pour 100000 habitants et quatre fois
moyenne procureur pour cent mille
habitants en france que dans la moyenne
de l'europe donc la justice la france
n'a pas tout à fait les moyens
par contre ce que je dis toujours c'est
que la justice française avec son
inventivité avec son adaptabilité et n'a
pas à rougir de ce qu'elle fait parce
qu'avec les moyens qui sont les
critiques qui sont portées à la justice
sont toujours intéressantes à entendre
j'essaie toujours d'être attentif c'est
toujours sain et utile d'entendre les
critiques mais je dis toujours que
chaque pays à la justice qui veut bien
se financer et que je j'affirme que avec
les moyens que dont nous disposons nous
n'avons pas à rougir de ce que nous
faisons parce que on est souvent c'est
aussi une expression que j'ai mes
employés on est des bricoleurs on
bricole souvent mais on est des
bricoleurs de génie et le système
fonctionne plutôt mieux que ce que l'on
dit dans le grand public notamment
chaque année en france plus de 55000
personnes sont déclarées disparues
la plus grande partie d'entre elles sont
des mineurs est en général elles sont
retrouvés mais pas toutes certaines
affaires sont alors la une des journaux
nous avons décidé de nous intéresser au
travail de recherche de ces disparus
le mood at-on vous trouvé notre fille tu
vas avoir neuf ans le 5 mai à la joyeuse
dynamique sportive à nous manque
terriblement août 2017
tout le monde ou presque se souvient la
petite maelys âgé de 9 ans vivant dans
le haut-jura disparaît lors d'un mariage
en isère d'importantes recherches sont
menées pendant plusieurs semaines mais
en vain malheureusement miley c'est loin
très loin d'être la seule à manquer à sa
famille en france chaque année 50 mille
mineurs disparaissent près d'un millier
d'entre eux sont victimes d'enlèvements
de soustraction parentale ou se
volatilise sans raison apparente
les gendarmes et les policiers sont les
premiers contacts de leurs familles
le cas classique c'est l'appel du parent
qui à 18 heures qui rentrent du travail
et l'enfant n'est pas à l'école voilà il
a pris le bus
et puis ensuite te confier l'enfant plus
de nouvelles donc là on est vraiment sûr
de l'enquète disparition inquiétante
élan basculera rapidement dans le
domaine judiciaire
le parquet diligente alors de nombreux
moyens sur le terrain il faut aller vite
et recueillir un maximum de
renseignements
c'est très important c'est que notre
saisine soit soit très proche de la
disparition
quinze minutes des fois peuvent faire la
différence l'actualité le prouvent trop
souvent certaines affaires reste dans
une impasse malgré les efforts et les
moyens déployés depuis dix ans un office
de la police judiciaire situé à nanterre
peut intervenir dans les dossiers
difficiles on a des services un peu
spécialisés qui nous permettent de faire
des recoupements entre des dossiers qui
nous permettent de travailler sur des
domaines très techniques comme la
téléphonie par exemple mais on fait
aussi une sorte de relecture du dossier
pour vérifier si un certain nombre de
pistes n'aurait pas été abandonnées ou
pas exploitées tout simplement pour des
raisons valables la plupart du temps
dans 95% des cas les disparitions de
mineurs sont des fugues de quelques
jours quelques heures parfois pour des
motifs paraissant futile dans tous les
cas policiers et gendarmes lancent les
recherches
même si c'est une fuite ça fait une
fugue qui tourne mal une fugue ou la
personne est mal est renversée sur le
sur la route une fugue ou ça se passe
mal avec une bagarre je dirais avec
d'autres jeunes
enfin voilà de toute manière il y aura
la mise en place d'un dispositif
l'association sont seize mille enfants
disparus apporte par téléphone un
soutien juridique et psychologique aux
familles la plupart des appels
concernent des adolescents fugueurs
certains ne donne plus signe de vie
pendant plusieurs semaines plusieurs
mois ces jeunes moins bien protégée ne
sont pas conscients du danger les jeunes
qui sont déjà placés par l'aide sociale
à l'enfance ou des jeunes de milieux
plus fragiles et qui vont fugué partir
en errance finalement sont considérés
par par tout un chacun comme devenu
autonome capable de se débrouiller
malheureusement ce sont souvent des
jeunes très peu scolarisés et qui vont
peut-être rapidement basculé dans une
sorte de délinquance pour survivre et
donc être fragilisé est pris en charge
par des plus âgés qui vont profiter d'un
finalement pour des petits trafics ou
voire de la prostitution
[Musique]
le risque pour ces mineurs c'est de
tomber complètement dans l'oubli une
fois leur majorité révolue en france
toute personne majeure saine d'esprit a
le droit de disparaître
les recherches sont menées seulement si
la disparition est jugée inquiétante
alors il ya un certain nombre de cas qui
est la majorité des cas où on peut
comprendre pourquoi est inquiétant de sa
disparition pour des personnes âgées
voilà qui s'enfuit de la maison de
retraite pour des gens dont on sait
qu'ils ont des tendances suicidaires
extrêmement importante parce que les
proches ne l'ont dit en revanche
lorsqu'on est effectivement dans les cas
de figure de personnes jeunes même deux
majeurs qui d'un moment à l'autre
disparaître en laissant tout chez eux
enfin voilà s'évapore j'allais dire là
on peut effectivement ouvrir ensuite une
information judiciaire pour que les
investigations se poursuivent sur un
plus long terme
les exemples ne manquent pas célia or
zaz jeunes haut-saônoise disparu avec
son père dans la région de toulouse en
décembre dernier leur voiture a été
retrouvée incendiée narumi kurosaki
étudiants japonaise à besançon est
recherché depuis décembre 2016 la
justice est persuadé que la jeune fille
a été assassinée
son corps reste introuvable autre
disparition emblématique de la région
celle de sophie arnould originaire du
pays de montbéliard volatilisé le 4
septembre 1985 en plein maquis corse
cette affaire reste un mystère aux yeux
de la justice et de ses parents josette
et jacques se sont battus pendant de
très longues années
imaginant toutes les pistes pourrait
venir de la mer on savait qu'il y avait
de la prostitution
il y avait aussi des sectes voiliers et
puis hors des personnes mal
intentionnées parce que vous savez on le
voit encore maintenant vous avez des
personnes qui ce qu'est str quelquefois
je me dis on me dira elle est décédée
c'est terrible à dire je me tairai enfin
voila vous soyez à des personnes qui
veulent savoir comment ça s'est passé
c'est pas ça qui nous intéresse c'est de
savoir ce qu'elle a envie ou pas pendant
longtemps ils sont retournés en corse
ils ont sollicité des médiums des
voyants et comme beaucoup de parents ils
ont engagé un détective privé
si on découvre des éléments intéressants
ou important d'une piste quelconque qui
viendraient justifier une disparition
inquiétante peut-être un meurtre
d'enlèvement ou autre et bien bien
évidemment ça va être après les services
a nommé antique qui vont prendre le
relais souhaite la justice qui va s'en
saisir comme dans la sphère sophie
arnould le temps est le principal ennemi
des disparus et de leurs proches
malheureusement il faut pas se bercer
d'illusions je le crains fort que
quelqu'un qui soit disparue depuis très
longtemps un enfant disparu depuis très
longtemps on a très peu de chances de
retrouver vivante
je dirais que d'un cas des disparitions
inquiétantes la majorité des affaires ne
sont pas résolues on ne retrouve pas les
personnes c'est toujours terrible quand
vous avez des enfants qui n'avaient
aucune raison de disparaître
on ne retrouve ni les corps pour les
familles c'est terrible pour parce
qu'elles ne peuvent pas faire le deuil
et puis parce que nous on est là
effectivement pour leur expliquer ce qui
a pu se passer et on est toujours
extrêmement frustré évidemment lorsque
ce type d' enquête n'aboutit pas ça ça
pèse quand même sur volée pour là parce
que c'est vrai que tous les jours sauf
us et on se réveille la nuit
qu'est ce qu'elle fait est ce qu'elle
est décédée c'est ça c'est le fait de ne
pas savoir
même si les chances sont minimes
certaines familles poursuivre leur
combat lutte contre l'oubli
certaines de ses anciennes affaires
c'est col caisse sont suivis par l'unité
spéciale de police judiciaire
c'est important de garder le lien avec
la famille c'est important aussi que le
dossier vive soit médiatisé que
quelqu'un en parle parce qu'on n'est pas
à l'abri d'avoir un témoignage même
longtemps après témoignage qui pourrait
être décisif
aussant 16000 non plus on n'abandonne
pas comme un symbole un immense mur a
été érigé avec les photos des enfants
disparus
on se dit que ce sont des enfants dont
souvent hormis leurs parents ils sont
oubliés de tous et on se dit que
potentiellement ils peuvent un jour se
reconnaître ça c'est quelque chose de
très important parce qu'on pense
toujours qu'un enfant qui a disparu dans
des circonstances un peu bizarre peut
avoir été tué par un criminel ce qui est
malheureusement souvent le cas mais ils
peuvent aussi avoir été enlevée être
toujours vivant ailleurs il ne pas
savoir d'où ils venaient pour les
familles de ces disparus le temps
parfois rend la douleur plus discrète
certains comme josette et jacques ont
réussi à laisser la vie reprendre le
dessus sans jamais perdre l'espoir aussi
ténu soit il
[Musique]
marie vin dit on est dans cette salle du
tribunal correctionnel salle d'audience
que que vous connaissez bien
oui très bien j'y venais souvent j'y
viens deux à trois fois par semaine vous
êtes chroniqueuse judiciaire dans la
presse quotidienne régionale et vous est
aussi écrivaine c'est comme ça qu'on dit
vous écrivez des polars notamment est ce
qu'il ya un lien entre les deux et
comment vous le faites à bien sûr il ya
un lien
moi j'écrivais des polars avant de
d'être chroniqueur judiciaire mais
évidemment c'est toujours des sujets qui
m'ont intéressé et je pense que de
fréquenter assidûment les prétoires ça
aussi beaucoup changé mon écriture et
voilà en tout cas les sujets que j'avais
envie de traiter c'est plus
vraisemblable c'est du coup n'est
semblable et ça m'a permis de
m'intéresser à des choses qui sont moins
dans le sensationnel type grand tueur en
série ou grands criminels mais plutôt à
une banalisation de la violence à la
violence au quotidien et c'est plutôt et
aux origines de comment on fonctionne
tout ça et pourquoi des individus vont
se retrouver à 7 bar ou dans le box des
accusés
le roman noir le polar ça a souvent dans
la littérature était considérée comme un
genre mineur et on voit aujourd'hui
aussi qu'on se passionne de plus en plus
pour la justice pour le et ça n'est plus
le cas le roman noir n'est plus un genre
mineur au contraire on re découvre le
talent des auteurs l'intérêt pour pour
ce style littéraire est ce que ça va de
pair est ce que vous voyez des choses
évoluer ensemble
la société est de plus en plus
intéressés par les faits divers les
crimes et caetera et le polar retrouve
des lettres de noblesse finalement oui
c'est assez logique je pense que le le
polar qui a été une littérature
populaire
voilà donc moi c'est ce qui me plaît
aussi dans populaire c'est l'idée de
s'adresser à tous mais c'est aussi une
littérature du social une peinture du
sociétal et aujourd'hui on se pose
beaucoup de questions sur la manière
dont notre société évolue sur la manière
aussi dans la justice est rendue je
pense que ça participe de l'époque aussi
des réseaux sociaux où on est parfois de
plus en plus informés mais mal informés
aussi peut-être mais en tout cas ça
attise la curiosité de d'essayer de
comprendre comment tout ça fonctionne et
puis aussi peut-être se projeter dans
dans ces grandes affaires puisque plus
on avance plus peut-être qu'on se dit et
finalement il ya des choses ça aurait pu
m'arriver soit en tant que victimes
familles de victimes même en tant
qu'auteur vous passer de l'un à l'autre
de la fiction à la réalité comme
chroniqueuse judiciaire est ce que l'un
alimente l'autre et de quelle façon
oui tout à fait là alimente l'autre
c'est certain en tout cas le la réalité
m'inspire beaucoup et les grands faits
divers je compulse beaucoup de
documentation souvent je laisse reposer
très longtemps parce que j'ai pas envie
de traiter un sujet de manière trop
linéaire est trop trop brutale donc
souvent je mets le plusieurs histoires
que je mélange
voilà pour avoir plusieurs angles et
puis pour que ça soit pas la
retranscription d'une affaire existante
mon but c'est pas décrire des documents
c'est d'écrire de la fiction parce que
c'est un c'est complètement une autre
manière de traduire notre société
puisque à travers les personnages on a
développé de l'empathie pour les
personnages donc ça permet une meilleure
compréhension à mon sens enfin en tout
cas une compréhension qui complète ce
qu'on peut avoir dans les journaux ou
dans les documents pouvoir ressentir
voilà ce qu'on peut ressentir les
personnages voire s'identifier donc ça
c'est très important
donc bien sûr je me nourris de tout ça
ça va du petit détail qui va rendre le
propos très réaliste où on a
l'impression d'y être mais aussi ça
participe aussi d'une réflexion plus
globale
je pense que je mène de roman en roman
voilà / / / l'oeil que je peux avoir si
on a justice votre regard sur la justice
qui peut être à la fois critique mais en
même temps à l'intérieur aussi je pense
de voir ça au quotidien je pense
qu'aussi il ya des décisions de justice
par exemple qui me sont mois plus facile
à comprendre même si elles peuvent être
elles peuvent apparaître comme
révoltante mais disons quand on connaît
un petit peu le fonctionnement et le
fonctionnement aussi voilà savoir les
rôles de chacun dans cette justice et le
pourquoi du comment des si on y arrive
marie vernet dans cette émission on
parle aussi des crimes et les faits
divers qui ont eu lieu dans notre région
la bourgogne franche comté est ce que
cette région là elle est
particulièrement source d'inspiration
pour vous parce que on a l'impression
qu'il ya eu beaucoup d'affaires
ça aussi c'est certain parce que en fait
quand je suis passé de du statut de
simple lectrices à celui d'écrivaine
j'ai évidemment aussi été chercher de
documentation et un des premiers livres
sur lesquels je suis tombé c'étaient les
disparus de dos erres écrit par corinne
herrmann il retrace l histoire des
disparus enfin d'emile louis et de tout
ce qui a eu un auteur est tout ce qu'il
ya eu autour pardon et j'avoue que ça a
été vraiment un grand choc parce que
c'était d'un seul coup on efface thomas
harris et hannibal lecter et plongeant
au coeur de la bourgogne
et voilà et on est face à des choses
beaucoup plus sordides et surtout à des
interactions entre plusieurs perversion
et c'est ça qui m'a d'abord choquée mais
aussi fasciné pour reprendre cette
expression
d'avoir envie d'aller un petit peu aussi
voir de ce côté là et en bourgogne
effectivement ça vient aussi de
géographique manqué à ses centrales en
france donc on est aussi dans une région
de traversante ça ça marche pour les
affaires de stups beaucoup de gens qui
passent il ya beaucoup de gens qui
passent et il ya aussi je pense un
certain nombre de dispositions pour et
époux étaient liés à des tueurs des
routards du crime comme par exemple qui
est passée par là mais bon il ya surtout
emile louis et fournirait aussi qui a
fêté ses jours et puis il ya eu les
disparus de la 6c c'est cette affaire
qui inspire votre dernier ouvrage
justice soit elle aux éditions plon
marivin dit cette affaire elle vous a
particulièrement passionné oui alors
c'est une affaire que dont j'ai eu écho
depuis
depuis je suis tout petit en fait
puisque le meurtre de christelle blétry
je crois que c'est en 80 vérifier mais
en tout cas c'est au début des années 80
donc c'est cette jeune fille elle est là
c'est pratiquement ma génération
quelques années près donc j'ai entendu
parler de ces affaires j'ai eu
l'impression d'avoir grandi avec elle
d'autant que ça va durer dans le temps
après les autres disparaît le dernier
procès a été a été renvoyée l'a
dernièrement le procès en appel du
meurtrier présumé de christelle blétry
va être rejugé je sais pas quand du coup
mais ça devait être jugé en janvier
ça a été envoyée donc voilà on est
encore dans ces histoires et en
travaillant pour la presse locale c'est
vrai que j'ai suivis régulièrement les
articles qu'on pu paraître sur sur ces
sujets donc
et c'est en bourgogne aussi à cette
proximité qui est toujours un petit peu
voilà on peux me passer en voiture moi
je me promène beaucoup pour alimenter
vivre et pouvant avoir un petit peu les
lieux donc voilà on peut passer à des
endroits on se dire tiens ici on a
retrouvé le corps de la personne d'ici
là donc nos précédents qui s'est un
petit peu déformé par la profession la
profession permet à cherche mais mais
c'est très présent mais c'est très
présent cette région aujourd'hui vous
diriez que on est plus fasciné qu'avant
par par ces choses là ou bien c'est les
médias qui en font plus et on a ça donne
un peu cette impression là oui je pense
que c'est une impression
l'homme a toujours été fasciné par le
côté sombre
le côté obscur de l'humanité donc voilà
m
les ces crimes là et de lier aux faits
divers ces faits divers la ccsa quelque
chose de c'est arrivé près de chez vous
parce que là ça ressort on n'est pas
dans cette vision qu'on peut avoir
justement l'américaine qui a fait
longtemps pensé d'ailleurs aux policiers
aux gendarmes que il ya des tueurs en
série c pour qu'aux états unis
quelle idée saugrenue et que c'était pas
transposable en france alors que bien
évidemment c'est le cas mais il ya cette
voix là il ya ce côté c'est dans un
petit village c'est dans un lotissement
c'est tellement banal que finalement
c'est la projection c'est vraiment ça
c'est j'aurais pu être témoin ça aurait
pu m'arriver j'aurais pu être proches
des victimes j'aurais pu être victime
même pour une femme une jeune femme
comme j'ai pu l'être à cette époque là
donc donc oui cette fascination je pense
qu elle l est
elle sera toujours là depuis les
premiers jours d'août fait divers les
premiers journaux criminels je pense que
ça attise la curiosité
aujourd'hui je pense qu'on en sait un
peu plus on a plus de matières aussi
pour analyser ça pour analyser
psychologiquement le comportement des
auteurs pour pour analyser aussi la
détresse des victimes fin en avance
c'est un comprend mieux aussi le
processus de l'enquète on n'est plus au
courant les plus du fonctionnement de la
justice
et puis le les avancées scientifiques
permet aussi de résoudre un certain
nombre de crimes qui a et qui restait
encore très mystérieux et dont on a pu
avoir les solutions grâce grâce à l'adn
des dizaines d'amis dans l'actualité ces
derniers mois il ya le retour sur le
devant de la scène de la sphère du petit
grégory qui est évidemment traiter ici à
dijon même si la fère s'est passé dans
la région d'un côté vous diriez qu'un
jour on saura la vérité sur ce type
d'affaires justement grâce aux progrès
de la science et la jeunesse je ne sais
pas je ne sais pas quand mais je pense
que c'est très difficile aujourd'hui il
ya eu tellement de mensonges de parjure
etc
c'est un petit peu compliqué tellement
d'erreurs ont été faites aussi
au tout départ de cette enquête je suis
pas sûr qu'on n'y arrive vraiment mais
ceci dit c'est pas impossible qu'un
élément qui puisse être analysées
aujourd'hui apporte un certain nombre de
réponses ce qui est un petit peu dans
cette affaire ce qui est un petit peu
fou complètement disproportionnée c'est
le l'énergie qui a été miss et le sait
les sommes qui ont été mis avec des
enquêteurs qui ont travaillé une cellule
d'enquêté de neuf enquêteurs là qui ont
travaillé dernièrement avec un crime
pour reconstituer ça alors qu'on sait
que par ailleurs il ya d'autres affaires
non élucidées qui sont complètement
laissés à l'abandon
donc il ya aussi là pour le coup la
médiatisation de la fère a fait beaucoup
pour que financièrement on puisse aller
au bout et puis ce campus on puisse
chercher au delà je dirais presque au
delà du raisonnable
sauf évidemment je souhaite qu'on
retrouve un jour le véritable assassin
mais il ya une part à mon sens mon avis
personnel mais de l'exagération de
l'importance qu'on a donnée à cette
affaire là par rapport à d'autres qui
ont et qu'ils n'ont pas été médiatisée
et qui ont été totalement oubliés
parmi les affaires qui ont durablement
marqué notre région celle des disparues
de l'yonne bien sûr cette jeune fille
tout handicapées enfants de la dass
violée et tuée entre 1977 et 1979
derrière ces crimes un chauffeur de bus
emile louis une affaire qui a défrayé la
chronique à plus d'un titre
20 octobre 2013 emile louis décède dans
sa cellule de la prison de nancy où il
était incarcéré
l'un des plus grands tueurs en série du
20e siècle
condamné pour le viol et le meurtre de
cette jeune fille de la das de l'yonne
emporte avec lui ses mystères et milou
est parti avec ses secrets les familles
des victimes savent qu'elles ne
connaîtront jamais la vérité un regret
mais les au soulagement de ne jamais
voir le tueur en série libre la première
action c'est surtout de penser aux
victimes aux familles des victimes parce
que pour elle s'arrête une souffrance
supplémentaire parce que bon nombre
d'entre elles penser qu'avant de mourir
il dirait au moins la vérité soit 35
corps qui n'ont pas été retrouvés
puis je pense aussi aux victimes
vivantes qui avait peur qu'il ressorte
ont maintenant je pense qu'elles vont
être un peu plus sereine
marie julien et la soeur de madeleine de
juste l'une des victimes des mines oui
l'une des deux dont le corps a été
retrouvé
marie a peu donné à sa soeur une
sépulture digne mais aujourd'hui
quarante ans après le drame
elle pense encore aux cinq autres
familles de disparus à leur peine à leur
douleur
ça serait bien pour elle de les
retrouver oui pour ses forêts leur deuil
depuis l'enterrement des filles quoi ce
qu'il en reste
ça fait beaucoup quand même il reste
encore cinq à retrouver je pense qu'on y
trouvera pas avec son secret ça ça reste
ça reste gravé là dedans mais bon on
peut rien maintenant c'est fini
les faits remontent aux années 70
entre 1975 et 1979
cette jeune femme âgés de 15 à 26 ans
déficiente mentale disparaissent dans
l'yonne sans laisser de traces toutes
sont sous tutelle de la dass et placé en
foyer
mais pendant des décennies personne ne
s'inquiète de ces disparitions et les
services sociaux parle de simple fugue
didier seban et corinne herrmann avocats
des familles des disparus s'interroge
toujours sur l'action de la justice
ces jeunes femmes parce qu'elles étaient
handicapés parce qu'elles étaient
abandonnées parce que certaines avaient
une famille mais malheureusement elles
avaient été recueillis par la dass eh
bien ces jeunes femmes n'intéressait
personne et
la justice qui est malgré tout la
normalement pour protéger les plus
faibles a failli à sa mission
dès 1981 quelques années à peine après
les premières disparition un gendarme
mène pourtant l'enquète il s'appelle
christian jambet lui-même puppy de la
dass il retrace le parcours de chacune
des dix pages à chaque fois le même
homme sur leur route
emile louis un homme déjà condamné pour
attentat à la pudeur sur des mineurs de
la dass confié à sa campagne
ludovic berger est journaliste au
quotidien local donne républicaine il a
suivi la sphère des disparues de l'yonne
pour lui le travail du gendarme jambert
a été ignorée ou jambert dans un premier
temps enquêté à trouver des éléments à
rassembler des éléments et atrg
énormément de gens et lui qui était
connu pour être un fin limier un très
bon enquêteur
on a conclu que toutes les pistes
orienté du côté des mines oui dans son
enquête
christian jambert fait le lien entre
emile louis alors chauffeur de car qui
transporte régulièrement les jeunes
handicapés et les disparitions déjà
inquiété par la justice à plusieurs
reprises l'homme et à chaque fois
relâchés
thierry fournée a beaucoup travaillé sur
cette affaire et réalisé plusieurs
documentaires
pour lui le constat est sans appel
christian jambert avait découvert qui
était le responsable il avait fait ce
fameux rapport de synthèse qui n'a
jamais été pris en compte puisque le
juge d'instruction de l'époque de n'a
pas voulu poursuivre n'a même pas voulu
entendre
emile louis sérieusement n'a pas voulu
le mettre en examen là dessus le fameux
rapport jambert le voici sept pages daté
de juin 1984 des années d' enquête
consignes et des dizaines de témoignages
recueillis et un procès verbal qui
désigne imminent comme le principal
suspect ce rapport est remis au
procureur de la république de l'époque
rené meyer mais aucun des témoins retenu
par le gendarme est entendu par la
justice
classée sans suite le dossier finira au
fond d'un tiroir oublier pendant des
années par le tribunal d'auxerre
c'est sûrement l'enquêteur qui a avec
les moyens de l'époque n'avaient pas
l'adn fait la première enquête de police
scientifique et on doit lui rendre
hommage donc ce qui m'a toujours référé
c'est que la hiérarchie de la
gendarmerie
le système judiciaire n'ait rien fait de
cette enquête qui était très construite
et qui a servi de base à l' enquête qui
a permis de poursuivre emile louis
ensuite pourquoi la justice n'a pas n'a
pas voulu suivre ça c'est vraiment assez
incompréhensible on voit très bien sur
le dossier sur le rapport de synthèse
mme écrit non aux stylos qui a écrit ce
nom est ce que juge d'instruction est ce
le procureur chacun se reporte un peu la
responsabilité
voilà mais en tous les cas l'enquète n'a
pas été fait
et pendant ce temps là des jeunes femmes
continuent à disparaître
mais un autre homme va lui aussi
s'obstiner à faire éclater la vérité
dans cette affaire
cet homme c'est pierre monard un simple
citoyen de l'yonne dont le frère est
handicapé il crée une association
regroupe les familles de disparus et se
démène en 1996 il porte plainte et fait
éclater le scandale dans les médias
le parquet d'auxerre et contraint
d'ouvrir une information judiciaire
vous savez lorsqu'on démarre une affaire
comme ça lorsqu'on tire les 1re ficelle
franchement se rend pas compte parce
qu'on pense que les toutes les
institutions sont sont dirigés par des
gens normaux qui vont réagir à des viols
dans les institutions etc et et on pense
que tout va fonctionner que la justice
fonctionne que l'état fonctionne
or ça n'a pas été le cas emile louis de
son côté quitté l'yonne pour le sud de
la france
il y clame son innocence
les hommes charles sirois et qui suis
absolument pour rien j'ai toujours clamé
mon innocence
en décembre 2000 emile louis et placé en
garde à vue
à draguignan pour une autre affaire
accusé de viols avec tortures et actes
de barbarie sur sa compagne
encouragés par les gendarmes croyant les
faits prescrits
le chauffeur de car passe aux aveux dans
la sphère des disparues de l'yonne
transféré à auxerre
emile louis se fait plus précis
emile louis a avoué avoir tué les sept
jeunes filles dont les familles se sont
constituées parties civiles
après avoir eu des relations sexuelles
librement consentie at il indiqué il a
expliqué son comportement par des
pulsions incontrôlées les aveux se
poursuivent et les fouilles des buts sur
ses indications de squelettes sont
retrouvés à rouvres est un endroit où
l'homme avait l'habitude de pêcher
vingt ans plus tôt des ossements humains
viennent d'être découverts aux premiers
endroits indiqués par emile louis les
adn prélevé parle
les corps sont sous lé madeleine de
justes et jacqueline based deux des
disparues
les emile louis revient sur ses aveux et
se mure dans le silence
il brouille les pistes
emile louis était une personnalité
extraordinaire j'ai coutume de dire que
c'est un peu le dernier criminel d'une
france rurale
la fin du 19e siècle ou du début du
xxème même s'il a commis ces meurtres
dans les années 1970 d'un homme qui
avait su se fondre dans dans l'univers
de l'yonne du département en étant
proche des notables respectueux des
notables respectueux de la gendarmerie
finalement un homme bien sous tous
rapports dont on ne pouvait pas imaginer
qu'il avait le comportement qui dit elle
a eu avec les disparues de l'yonne et
c'est son cynisme sa bonhomie entre
guillemets socialiste quand on
rencontrait on avait l'impression que
c'était un bon bougre quoi il a réussi à
donner cette impression ce qui l'a
sûrement ce qui lui a sûrement permis de
passer au travers des gouttes pendant
longtemps novembre 2004 près de 25 ans
après les faits le procès des 1000 ou et
s'ouvre tribunal d'auxerre pour les
familles des victimes
l'attenté grande s'est chargée d'émotion
et de beaucoup d'espoir que les familles
des disparues de l'yonne sont arrivés en
ce jour d'ouverture du procès au palais
de justice d'auxerre toutes avaient tenu
à être présente un accès rétracter je
pense qu'il restera sur
je sais réserve qui démentira tout ce
qu'on peut lui reprocher tu si seulement
il pouvait dire où sont les autres
les autres corps et les familles face
loudun le procès va durer un mois
à la barre emile louis continue de nier
pour les familles la souffrance est
insupportable en particulier lors du
retour sur le lieu des fouilles
là où deux corps ont été retrouvés sur
les indications des millions
j'ai ressenti j'ai ressenti une douleur
dans le pain de quelqu'un qui nie qui
arrive à donner des endroits et qui nie
c'est tout il est condamné à perpétuité
peine confirmée en appel à paris mais le
mystère emile louis demeure on croyait
qu'il allait parler aux deux procès mais
n'a pas dit un mot
oui bien sûr tout pour les autres c'est
un fait encore quand même ça qu'ils sont
pas retrouvés l'avocat de la partie
civile didier ce bond a parfois essayé
de le faire sortir de ses gonds pour
montrer qu'ils étaient emile louis quand
il était en face de colère quand il
était sous l'emprise de la bestiole que
me décrit mais lui lors de ses aveux en
décembre 2000 mais on l'a pas vraiment
vu mail et partech ses secrets il était
pervers jusqu'au bout parce qu'il aurait
pu à la fin soulager sa conscience
mais bon ça fait partie de la
psychologie de ces individus à auxerre
une stèle est érigée à la mémoire des
disparus de l'yonne
à ce jour cinq des sept jeunes femmes
n'ont toujours pas été retrouvées et
peut-être bien d'autres encore
c'était un tueur en série il a été
condamné pour d'autres faits qui étaient
relatifs à des enfants je suis convaincu
qu'il y avait d'autres affaires avant et
après les disparues de l'yonne sur la
vingtaine de femmes qui ont disparu il y
en a eu il y en a sept qui ont été
reconnus naudon rôle et milou et a
reconnu qu'il les avait tués
d
qu'est-il advenu les autres ont servi à
toujours des mystères des femmes
disparues dont on ne sait pas ce
qu'elles sont devenues il y avait à
creuser beaucoup plus toutes façons ces
gens là n'arrête pas moi j'estime qu'une
estimation est tout à fait personnel je
pense qu'il ya une trentaine de jeunes
femmes qui sont passés entre ses mains
[Musique]
emile louis at il bénéficié de
protections
pourquoi le rapport du gendarme jambert
at il été si longtemps ignorer quelles
sont les vraies responsabilités de la
justice et des institutions dans cette
affaire des disparues de l'yonne
aujourd'hui encore de nombreuses
questions restent sans réponse
[Musique]
voilà c'est la fin de cette émission se
retrouve le mois prochain bien sûr pour
un nouveau numéro d' enquête de région
et d'ici là
prenez soin de vous
[Musique]